hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to totally accurate
battle simulator i haven't played this
in a few years actually how many years
have it been since i played this it's
been that many years since i played this
game and in that time there's been a lot
of updates i don't know what they are
but i'm gonna see about this campaign
what would the
collection of fun energy tactically
challenging
i don't actually want this for any kind
of like
tactics i want this because there is no
logic and reason to anything that's
happening in this game whatsoever and
therefore
i simply want to cause it as much chaos
as i possibly can and therefore i will
do that that's always been what this
game is about it's never been anything
deeper than that all right let's start
simple
because
like really in all honesty
people always like to go grandiose with
these things but because it is a
simulator game i do kind of want to have
some semblance of you know order to this
how do i play go there we go
you missed you literally
you both know
good god jesus christ
press tab to con what
okay let's make it to 2v2 because that's
going to be fair
[Music]
you both oh no you missed okay he's
coming back from the end from the brink
from the brink of the edge all one
friend down who's gonna make the final
blow
red comes up with a somersaulting back
twist
and the blue hat it above his head and
not defending his
tender
where did you get hit do you get hit in
the ribs
oh
sorry bud and he's dead nice hands
he says great form on him uh he made the
mistake of never actually swinging his
club all right 3v3
go
did you all miss or is some people
actually dead here no all sneak attack
holy crap
that was the most devastatingly brute
look at the murder in his eyes he knows
he knows what he did and i can't get a
good look at him is there a way to crawl
slow mouse in his left button
okay can i slow motion my movement
oh okay let's double up because
red team seems to have been getting a
clobbering and it's not exactly fair
slow motion
oh yeah that's good stuff
damn
holy crap
oh the beef oh
oh that would have been deadly if it
actually landed
okay the scoop the swoop the swing the
swan no you're not oh ho ho but he lived
holy oh it's 4v1 let's see if he can
john wicket
oh god taken out by his own teammate
oh that was right to the jaw okay brain
what you smacked your own friend and
somehow that's a
that's it
you did a sweet dab on the way out
though that didn't make much sense to me
man red team just getting clobbered well
they got the sun in their eyes or
something come on
oh the height some of these guys get
i don't know i think they
they improved the physics engine
definitely
oh
okay blue got snobbered
oh
gross
oh you got your own friend oh my god
well they're all bunched up
swift dodge oh my god death dealt oh my
god he's a beast
he's a beast he's unstoppable
holy
oh my god he just wanted his team to go
down oh never mind
he's dead well at least that's finally a
victory for uh you guys what does
stoners do oh you
don't know i expected it to be anything
all right go go for it guys you got this
come on
what's that
man you should have
ducked man you should have ducked is
there like a replay button
oh here we go
well that was very nice um let's try two
and let's see how that goes
all right good luck guys
okay they hit in mid-air
met well red has the initiative on the
reload that doesn't seem fair hang on
let's get some artillery going how far
can you guys throw this actually
let's see how far these from downtown
all right well that did a whole lot of
nothing let's give some more dynamicism
okay here comes chungo bonk here's
omgwongo
now
miss nice jump though
okay here we go
red does have the initiative this guy
this poor guy
oh two for one sale
oh well that guy got clobbered
oh
my god all right well duck
[Music]
[Laughter]
he didn't duck man he just told him to
duck he did not duck all right um
what what happens i'm just i i love
throwing rocks you know a few more let's
make it even okay here we go that's even
all right the rocks are in coming guys
oh man now it's just sad when it gets to
a scale it's sad it's not funny anymore
you know because this is just the
horrible realities of war
no guys please no please have mercy
please mercy mercy
man
no mercy on that okay well that's sad
get out of here we're not here for sad
what's a bone mage
go
mage it up
what did you do
[Music]
then let's get some more
lucky number 13.
okay so bone mages are completely op
that's what i'm getting unless we have
protectors okay i know the spikes come
from underground and so shields oh oh
god oh this is sad oh one's coming in
never mind he's very dead all right so
that didn't help what about with
like stoners in the back can you even
throw over their heads i really hope you
can throw over their heads
good god
oh
payback's a [ __ ] watch out you've got
shields coming in
i think i got blunt okay chieftain oh
this should be fun should be a battle
for the ages
never
it's mind not a battle for anything
jesus that was pathetic what about two
they're just strong put some clubbers in
there
get some clubbers clubbing
bonk wow there's this blue team just
sucks okay
all right go for it guys
remember blue team
get him buddy
okay two can play at this game pal
no not this guy i want to possess that
guy thank you
i win
what happened let's try that again
oh
oh
that's good oh
oh bye friend
hey you're still alive
how's it going down there
how are you doing belle
oh no wait my dude oh
good god
yeah play dead my friend no please
not like this
no okay well that's one okay tribal
farmer medieval ancient viking dynasty
renaissance pirate spooky wild west
legacy good evil secret what's legacy
uh with the old version
but these aren't
hey peasants i don't remember peasants
what did peasants do
anything
good god oh my god damn
these peasants got an uppercut
biff
home
bam
bam
god damn all right well let's go nuts
with the clubbers
it's like i'm power washing clubbers
into existence they got to be able to
take down one mammoth you know what i
mean oh now we're getting my computer to
lag this is what i'm talking about
there we go my computer can catch up can
you guys do anything
you guys uh
man you guys you guys would not survive
the winter if you can't take down one
mammoth oh i just don't think that
they're actually doing any damage to it
oh they win
oh no it's fine there were so many dudes
there were so many this guy's a champ
this guy's a champ this guy's a champ
he's got this oh
well he was about to win because he he i
think in the end he baited it off the
mountain and so
oh oh
oh
how you doing pal you all right you're
right buddy you seem to be in a bit of a
predicament and then he'd be dead there
forever and that's how a skeleton would
get there and people would be very
confused what about like stoners there's
gotta be a methodology of just throwing
enough rocks at a mammoth would
theoretically win
right if you throw enough rocks oh
wow
the clubbers just didn't do anything
they just sucked
all right well that's the answer to that
all right let's explore some of this
a hay baler
oh
[Music]
i don't know what i was thinking i don't
know what i was thinking
all right you hobbits
[Music]
okay uh you're gonna hold hands or
whatever
oh
god i'm running the heart okay well that
was
that was interesting potion seller okay
what does potion seller do
[Music]
all right and while we answer that
question
interesting
[Music]
what is your face what is wrong with you
i'm so afraid
i've never been more afraid
what's wrong with your neck is that your
chin or is that your neck
all right keep it up
yeah keep nailing right in the junk
that's gonna win you
yeah i don't i don't know if this is the
right strategy pal
yeah you keep going for the balls but i
think that guy's dead all right i'm
gonna call this one a draw are you guys
are just the front line
leading the charge of the most
incredible wheel barrel destruction
derby the world has ever seen
damn
[Music]
oh my god
all right good job
scarecrow now is a scarecrow actually
something that does anything or what
does this oh my god
oh
oh my god
who won
sure okay that's terrifying so let's do
a back line of scarecrows
oh yeah that's going to lag me up versus
hay balers no
wheel barrelers
hay balers
potion sellers
farmers
and then
harvesters
go
[Music]
get them
oh my god
okay their crows have respawned for the
second volley so i guess they were a
little bit far for that to work
hmm
are you guys okay
you guys all right okay i say boring
what else we got medieval
bard
nah
yeah what does bart do
[Music]
see what you guys do
[Laughter]
that's not funny man
do you like pump up your
your
fellow dudes is that what you do
you pump no dude just
can you like at least sue the mammoth or
something is is there like some other
point to you
is there a point
i give you some more space there you go
pal there you go pal you got some space
on you all right you got him this time
buddy you gotta miss time
[Music]
god
all right so it doesn't soothe let's get
a healer there for you so you can heal
that damage oh yeah get him full of heel
juice that's really gonna get him
oh wow
okay well he's dead now lead him off the
mountain
oh
epic strategy i can't believe he's
surviving
he's alive
never mind
the king is in town
we got the whole squad here this guy
don't stand a chance this guy don't
stand a freaking chance
it's like a raid boss in here damn
damn
[Applause]
dog kicking
okay oh
yay okay we did it i guess winning is
beating the creature that just wanted to
survive how about a catapult versus a
bard
this is the kind of contest i like that
he's alive
he's unstoppable unflappable he can't be
flapped no one's ever flapped him he's
coming for you [ __ ] this bard's ready
to kill
he's unbeatable
you'll never stop
[Music]
you'll never beat him
jeez
you okay all right ancient
shield bearer the minotaur
okay
oh
well that that clearly wasn't fair i
didn't mean to do that
i didn't mean to do that
meant to do this
where'd you go
soothe the savage beast soothe it
choose the beast
soothe it shoot the beast
the beast
[Music]
he's fine okay so that is a totally
accurate battle simulator haven't played
in a while still gives me some good
laughs i love a good rag doll i really
like a ragdoll if you watch the heist
with markiplier you definitely know that
there are some moments in there with
ragdolls in it in fact hopefully we can
put a clip of it in right now
so if you haven't seen a heist with
markiplier go check that out also if you
want to play totally accurate battle
simulator you can go find it in the link
in the description below it's on the
epic game store and you can use my
creator code markiplier in the epic game
store as well let me know if you want to
see more of this i guess it's always
kind of fun i do enjoy it it's silly
it's nice what's a da vinci
well we'll find out later if you guys
want to see it or play for yourself
thank you and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you